i think the tortilla could be a little
bit more crispier though no no no i
think it's perfect the way it is don't
get defensive no i don't do i start
telling you how to make spotted dick or
or whatever the hell you make at home
welcome to scrambled where i take on
some new friends old friends with my
favorite dish today i've got one of the
best mexican chefs anywhere on the
planet we go back a long way he is
my little brother from a different
mother please welcome chef ron sanchez
thank you very much gordon for having me
appreciate it good to see you captain i
see the budget's gotten bigger thanks
come on really yeah anyway it's not it's
not about the backdrop but what goes on
the pan i agree yes i agree not only are
you a prolific judge standing alongside
me on a daily basis but you are the
mexican james bond of cuisine where does
that come from well i just think the
idea of being this good looking and
talented you can probably uh blame my
parents for that a little bird told me
this morning that you were voted
from people magazine one of the most
beautiful people in the world did you
stuff the ballot box no uh i think i
started stuffing myself after that fame
but uh that was 10 years and 40 pounds
ago right you know what
it was a lot of fun to uh kind of
recognize by the magazine that's
somebody that's attractive yeah i know
that yeah and listen congratulations by
the way but what were you 14 15 at the
time no i was not just asking now i
launched humble pie 10 years ago uh it
meant a lot for me to write i could have
done that without my mother
you've just launched chores how hard was
it writing that book i'm using this book
as an opportunity to inspire others i
wanted people to know that it's not an
easy ride you know all the different
things that you and i do in our world
it's still the cooking is the most
important part family yeah and
foundation and that comes across yes i
see it well i appreciate that now um
i'm going to take you on with scrambled
eggs but you wanted to be an authentic
mexican scrambled egg so we're going to
do inside a breakfast
taco breakfast tacos are all the rage
nowadays and for me the traditional way
of doing is always started with chorizo
eggs and some sort of potato so you're
telling me now how to make scrambled
eggs yes i am okay absolutely yeah yeah
you bet your sweet ass i'm telling you
that might the best man win all right
yeah let's go you're dead mate give me
an insight to some of the early
dishes that you grew up you remember
with mom because i mean she was a
prolific chef yeah my mom had a
restaurant in new york city for 30 years
and really
the idea was to take all the traditional
food that she had grown up eating on a
cattle ranch in mexico and bring it to
the biggest food audience in the world
which is new york city yep so she had to
overcome a lot of adversity a lot of
self-doubt and then i kind of went along
the ride along the ride with her right
it was one of the most harrowing
experiences i've ever seen i have so
much respect for my mom yep she has done
so much not only just for me but for a
generation of mexican chefs sure so i
made a lot of initial trips to mexico
and all over latin america to make sure
i educated myself so i spoke from
position of
of strength so you went off the beaten
track you sort of almost
opposite what she did exactly and then
brought that back to the fold exactly
and i needed to develop my own style and
that was one of the biggest things my
mentors had mentioned to me early on
yeah were don't regurgitate what your
mom and what your mentors do find your
culinary voice yes and let it be clear
for everyone to hear you know you know
the deal yeah you don't want to you know
do things that your mentors taught you
you want to step away you
have
authenticity
across your food you're very passionate
about what you do
you're a loving dad
what's with all the tattoos okay now
initially yes
uh you know when i started cooking in
the kitchens it was a great place to
kind of be a little bit of a misfit an
outlaw a rebel and tattooing early on
was really part of that kind of image i
guess i wanted to portray i loved how
rock and roll it was right and then it
kind of took off from there i have a lot
of friends that are tattoo artists and
now i co-own a tattoo shop so just to
show you but they're everywhere yes is
it is there anywhere on your body that
doesn't have a tattoo uh
i have one butt cheek that's kind of
bare right now you have one butt cheek
that is bare yeah so i'm waiting to
complete the butt cheek
and then uh
and then i'll truly be in tattoo bliss
exactly
give me the size of the foundation
because i've been following the
foundation over the last five years
you're sponsoring young chefs that
haven't been given opportunity yes now
the the kids that i'm working with are
from latin backgrounds young women and
men from all over the country and what i
saw initially when i started cooking was
that there was a disparity between some
latinos getting positions of leadership
in kitchens right so i wanted to provide
them with the foundation of the best
culinary education possible so so to
create this next generation of leaders
in the kitchen culture so i don't start
your scholarship fund it's doing
extremely well we have about five kids
enrolled into the program now and we're
going to put in probably another three
this year so amazing the proudest day of
your career would be what i've been
cooking at the white house a couple
times was pretty fantastic i had a
chance to cook for president bush and
for obama what was that like walking in
there
you know what i mean the pressure
and
the expectation were up the roof i
remember going there with my family
being like this is probably the most
important meal i'm ever going to cook in
my life so uh were you nervous i was
extremely nervous and trying to choose a
menu for heads of state
and all of their colleagues and figuring
out what's a universally liked menu you
know how it is you you cook for
royalty and for presidents you know the
deal um so
that for me was one of the biggest
highlights i guess what makes you
nervous
um
failure failure yeah
um not living up to
the expectation that people have of me
and you know letting people down i think
that right there
is something that every chef possesses
and contains
and you let either use that as a source
of strength or it can really consume you
so i guess that just the fear of failure
i'm sure that's something that concerns
you too
that's always in the back of my mind
yeah how important is it for you to be a
mexican being successful in america
today what is that what does that mean
for you today my father was from a town
of 200 people in the in the valley of
texas he was the first mexican american
to get a masters in the 50s for a
thousand miles so it's really about
honoring
honoring your legacy your family and
making sure that you're an example to
all those one unbelievable generation of
young kids that want to do what we do
every day sure so i think that really is
the goal and that's how it feels so
rewarding now away from the kitchen yeah
what relaxes you
um well you know i love spending time
with my family obviously just like you
do i love going to the beach i love
being on the water i love to dance like
i know you're a big fan of dancing
i mean
i saw your master chef junior brother
you were a hot mess
i've never seen a guy actually go
against the rhythm so much in my life i
i know i can't dance i mean with
scotland i'm known for no no drinking
but not dancing and every time i do
dance my daughters think i'm having a
fit exactly that's what i'm saying so
i'm not the only one
i love it
now the layering of a breakfast taco so
for me crispy tortilla or soft tortilla
sure let that be the base and then from
there we're going to go ahead
and uh
start working with your garnishes and
your salsa yes okay so you went bacon
onion mushroom right yes so very kind of
european a little bit chilly in there
there's a little bit of chili yeah some
scallions okay cool calories to finish
mine has a chorizo potato a little bit
of onion
a little tomato
and then then i like to put all my fresh
herbs at the end
right let's have a look at these side by
side
you still put bits on there yeah
now you're taking the pair so i've
finished
and you put the avocado
avocado do you know what means testicle
and aztec
so the aztec language the word avocade
means testicle put that in your next
book all right here you go hold on
move over a little soft
blue
all day long amigo um so describe yours
please i did first of all let's describe
it with delicious all right let's start
with that
chorizo a little bit of potatoes a
little onion of course a little salsa
so i have scrambled egg starting off
with a little bit of chorizo a mushroom
a bit of bacon in there finished with
some chili top with salsa and finish
with your cheese
you mean
one of the best cheeses ever okay
is there anything you didn't put on
there jesus look at that please please
please stop being fussy come on take one
of mine i'll take one of yours and here
we go expectations are high here chef
indeed
you fancified a breakfast taco for the
love of the baby jesus but you know what
i'm happy you did it because it's yummy
yours is delicious really good i think
the tortilla could be a little bit more
crispier though no no no i think it's
perfect the way it is don't get
defensive no i don't do i start telling
you how to make spotted dick or
or whatever the hell you make at home
well done senor may you always continue
to make tacos okay consider me your
mexican messiah i will free you from bad
mexican food
thank you right that's it for scrambled
please leave a comment below on who you
think has done the best
you shared the name with another famous
arron sanchez
basketball player no no a baseball
players oh yeah i better get that right
there's too many sports here
[Music]